[Music]
for most people
sunday is just the day before Monday
but for us Sunday's everything break
yourself oh look what you did to my
curtains you better watch you win are
you climbing in for you get blasting off
with what you ain't got nothing man with
this stop playing and come outside hold
on I got something for you hurry up man
Oh Bobby those are ugly as hell tonio
matter of fact let me post a pic on the
ground Oh beep
[Applause]
Oh Dell Antonio can we talk for a second
oh what's that fool you know is booming
man I wanted to catch you before the
game your what happened - dude you ass
nah man hey James can I can I talk to
you for a second what up man
since we're not on the same team anymore
I was wondering could I have my bike
back oh the beach cruiser I didn't know
you wanted it back oh it's right here
just my talk and I'm keeping the
playbook - hands survived the ground mmm
I'll never figure out what a catch is
you'll never mind what a catch is OB we
need to get ourselves some of those hey
give me one of them rings mr. Brady oh
[ __ ] here comes McAdoo what about Tony
Oh what up Obie McAdoo what you want oh
I need to borrow your microwave right
quick
I can wait what kind of [ __ ] is that you
need to borrow a job at your broke ass
get the hell on record ooh
imma remember that Antonio by McAdoo
yeah you guys are stingy Tonio huh come
in for a second that's you coach we went
in the bathroom coach I'll wait for you
to come out Tonio bring your ass off up
in here I'm talking are you gonna wait
till I come out we don't face book life
grab that you can't deal with my for
five minutes
coach this is super weird baby if you
want to win it all you got to be a pass
catcher I'm already a receiver pears
catch a pass ketchup you see a
quarterback and you come and catch
passes on his ass like bang bang bang
bang
coach can you please stay out of my
house
what's that thing you see business is
booming show it right in yo toilet Oh
smells like something died inside you
[Music]